are people who are sure we did not land
on the moon and they looked at the
photos of Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin
in daylight and they say we know you're
supposed to see stars in daylight and I
don't see any stars in this photo okay
so therefore we didn't really go to the
Moon I
so wouldn't know to fake that if that
were the case
are idiots that that kind of makes a lot
of sense if you know that well then we
the space people definitely knew it too
definitely know too why wouldn't we just
throw a little dots in the back and let
you see some Stars okay what the person
doesn't know is how photography works
okay the terrain is so bright from the
sun right the aperture of the camera
closes down and cannot register the like
the same things such as the stars in the
sky so that's why that's how that plays
out there you go